[Musique]
recevoir une amende pour excès de
vitesse sur la route ça vous est
peut-être déjà arrivé
[Musique]
si en France le montant du pvfx certains
pays comme la Finlande ont décidé de
l'indexer sur le salaire si vous avez un
bon travail donc un revenu assez élevé
forcément l'amant des plus importantes
sanctionné davantage les plus aisés pour
une même infraction une mesure jugée
juste pour beaucoup de citoyens et
ferrich si vous êtes riche 20 euros ça
ne vous pénalise pas beaucoup mais si
vous n'avez pas d'argent vous le sentez
passer alors faut-il instaurer le même
système en France les riches doivent-ils
payer leur PV plus cher que les autres
on en parle ce soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est juste que ceux qui ont mis oui
parleront pas beaucoup
alors Jean-Marie tu mets oui je mais oui
bien sûr c'est une bonne idée c'est une
manière de répartir un petit peu après
tout ce qui ont la chance d'avoir un peu
plus et ben il cotise un petit peu plus
voilà tout simplement est-ce que d'idée
moi c'est ce qu'on disait quand on m'a
vu tout nu un jour comme tu as la chance
d'en avoir un petit peu plus pourquoi
séparé mais en fait ça veut dire quoi
riche en fait ça veut dire qu'à partir
de quand tu es la personne devra alors
justement ça c'est une question
incroyable bravo j'ai 3000 c'est 4000
j'ai 2000 c'est quoi être riche François
Hollande avec les appartements de 5000 €
en net on est voilà ce qui reste à la
fin du mois pour vous c'est quoi être
riche pour moi pour moi je vous dis la
vérité est riche pour moi
être riche c'est déjà être riche de cœur
et moi j'ai pas peur de prendre des
risques
combien combien
c'est la richesse c'est quand il nous
reste 1000 euros quand on a payé tout le
superflu ah ouais c'est bien parce que
on n'a pas les mêmes chats
déjà c'est pas possible c'est pas les
mêmes critères
donc toi tu es riche donc je me
considère comme riche effectivement
si 7000 nets
Jean-Marie oui oui moi je suis assez
d'accord avec Gilles pour une fois je
saute sur l'occasion
à partir de 4000 euros moi je dis que tu
es bien quoi alors moi je chante
des mythos sur la tête de ma mère mais
non c'est pas des mythos de ouf mais moi
très honnêtement riche ça veut dire
enfin moi j'imagine dans ma tête que
quelqu'un de riche c'est quelqu'un qui
ne pense pas à l'argent qui ne se soucie
pas de l'argent donc quand tu gagnes
quand il te reste 5000 euros tu te
soucies encore de l'argent pour moi dans
ma tête un riche c'est quelqu'un qui se
lève le matin et qui ne pense pas à ce
qu'il y a sur son compte en banque ou
est-ce payer les études des enfants etc
c'est ça un riche sinon c'est quelqu'un
qui est bien c'est ça quelqu'un qui a
bien dans sa vie quelqu'un de bien c'est
juste c'est pas ma définition en tout
cas jamais content il veut toujours être
plus riche mais ça veut dire que si on a
4000 si on a 4000 € par mois donc on
doit avoir des amendes plus
on paye si on gagne 8000 si on gagne
10000 on doit payer encore plus cher à
ça exactement alors c'est 400 € d'amende
pour un conducteur qui gagne 1000 euros
par mois
il doit payer beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
moins cher
parce qu'en Angleterre ils font ce
principe là ils ont plafonné c'est 10000
euros maximum d'amende alors que par
exemple en Finlande ça peut monter à
100000 150000 etc
parce que la mesure égalité c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme mesure
égalitaire c'est le permis à points
pour le coup quand tu fais une
infraction et tu te retrouves à perdre
ton poids bah tout le monde est pareil
et égal devant la loi tu retrouves sans
permis ou avec la Finlande
c'est incroyable je te jure et alors
c'est incroyable
ça permet de dire allez je vais faire un
cadeau aux pauvres et hop tu accélères
tu passes à 180 et hop tu dis je donne
100000 euros
il faut prendre à l'inverse regardez
chez nous les amendes de 135 euros 135
euros c'est 10% du SMIC Cyril le SMIC il
est à 1350 exactement il faut baisser
pour les gens
qui sont les plus pauvres et augmenter
pour les plus riches chatons sous le
sens enfin long quelqu’un a eu 54000
euros d'amende pour 23 km/h avec cette
vitesse bah ça c'est du génie voilà
j'entends ce que tu dis je suis d'accord
sur l'idée moi sur l'idée
on a déjà une mesure égalité qui pour
moi est permis à point mais dans ces
cas-là ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois que
on fait quelque chose et qu'on essaie de
s'élever et qu'on essaie de gagner un
peu plus d'argent on va nous taper
derrière la nuque et dans ces cas-là la
baguette alors elle va être plus cher
pour les riches et les autres
quand on témoin des animaux témoin tu
vas pouvoir commettre plus d'infraction
quand tu es riche mais non c'est
n'importe quoi ce que tu dis ouais c'est
ça en fait
comme tu dis ah bah non je m'en fous je
suis pauvre je peux y aller frère moi je
préfère je préfère qu'il fasse moi comme
j'ai dit à la fois oui verrons je
préfère qu'il fasse un super impôt mais
bien sûr
est-ce que c'est mon rêve moi sur la
tête mais moi je pense à ça la dernière
fois je disais voilà on sait que on voit
là en 2023 c'est une panier le covid
avant et à la guerre et tout ça on voit
que tout le monde est dans la merde ils
prennent ils prennent les je sais pas
moi les cent mille plus riches de France
il leur dit voilà en 2023 vous allez
payer contribution quand vous allez
payer genre vous allez payer un super
impôts qu'on va peut-être vous enlevez
en 2024 on va on va réguler mais en 2023
voilà les mecs tu leur envoies une
petite lettre voilà merci d'avoir
contribué genre les comme il se les
Brandt a eu la lettre toi ouais moi je
l'ai eu en bas j'ai eu la lettre
les souris qu'est-ce qu'ils pensent ils
pensent qu'à ses bras mon frère qu'elle
a faim ils vont dire quoi oh [__] t'as
vu qu'il a pas eu la lettre Guillaume
frère il la mettent sur insta ou alors
vous avez vu j'ai voilà j'ai ici je te
jure que j'ai participé c'est bien 2023
ils disent voilà on prend les 100000
plus riches il donne un peu plus et 2024
il en est on vous emballera ce que vous
avez donné en plus au moins comme ça ça
nous permet de voilà de d'avoir un peu
plus normalement on enlève pas
moyen on fait partie peut-être
pas d'impôts donc l'autre moitié paye
des impôts et être quand même à la
collectivité pour tout donc c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que moi je pense que pour
payer encore plus d'impôts pour conquis
il faut qu'ils envoient une petite
lettre ah ouais sur ma vie une petite
lettre République française on vous
remercie tu vois tu fais un kiffe tu
vois tu reçois la trollélé tu es comme
un ouf tu vois tu dis je suis content
d'être un super citoyen
il t'envoie même un truc avec une cape
dedans tu la mets quand même super
citoyen
tu fais ta vie c'est juste une branlette
je suis désolé de ce genre vous allez
donner combien
quoi
vous dites que vous êtes seriez prêt à
le faire si vous recevez l'être aimable
pourquoi vous rigolez quoi quand je dis
ça me fait chier
non mais je te le dis non non non non
en revanche le concept selon lequel 100
euros c'est rien pour les riches donc il
faut leur faire payer
l'essence plus cher les courses plus
cher il faut supprimer le concept même
de richesse ça sert à quoi de s'enrichir
si c'est pour repayer
proportionnellement à chaque fois moi ce
qui veut dire ce qu'on est en train de
dégoûter parce que gagner de l'argent
c'est quand même pas quelque chose de
mal on est en train de dégoûter les
Français de gagner de l'argent il faut
aider bien sûr à travers l'info on
pourrait faire un effort exceptionnel
certains ceux qui ont de l'argent pardon
vous avez fréquenté Castaldi
dernièrement j'ai dit on peut faire un
effort exceptionnel pendant une année
effectivement une année difficile
Delphine bonne idée c'est ça en fait
l'impôt il est là et des proportionnelle
et des proportionné pour ce qu'on gagne
en revanche quand on fait par exemple
des exacts ou des choses comme ça c'est
des infractions à la citoyen et donc
chaque citoyen doit être égaux
en fait entre gagner de l'argent quand
on travaille et le le comportement sur
la route
qui peut mettre en danger des gens et
ben c'est
pas ça
aux impôts
et tu nous fais plus chier
[Applaudissements]